[Music]
please welcome the very funny brett
morin
[Music]
hello
how are you hello angie
very pretty
i wish i didn't like pretty girls
i really do i wish i didn't like women
that are out of my league i think my
life would be easier if i just liked
horrible shapes you know just
this terrible looking alley cats just
shadow creatures you know
can't even make out what they are they
don't even speak a language it's just
sounds like i'm in the city at night
with my friends we pass a dark alley all
i hear is
i'm like hang on
boys i think i hear a princess
how'd you get all the way up there what
are you doing pull-ups uh
you got beautiful red eyes
but i don't i like women that are out of
my league and you women
another pretty one man
you women are mean you're very mean it's
hard to hit on you because women will
turn you down right away and then say
things you didn't need to know about
yourself
like just say no okay you already won i
don't need the add-ons like i'll be at a
bar i see a girl i like i'm like hey
what's up you're weird don't touch me
have a horrible body like you have a
terrible
body
like your body pushes in and stays
pushed in you know that right you have a
tempur-pedic body are you aware
that you have that it's like a sleep
number seven like you should know that
about don't look stay here my friends
need to see this amanda david he's gay
kristin come here
no bring your drinks you have to see
this push this body in kristin what is
that that's tempur-pedic thank you it's
like a pillow it's like a pillow body
it's not good david what would you say
sleep number seven thank you david
that's why we have a gay friend now go
drink and get in a fight
that's why we see fights between guys
like okay thank you
that's why we see fights between guys
like me we're being held back screaming
at each other like i'm gonna kick your
ass man what we really want to say is
hey i shouldn't have worn this shirt i
feel like an idiot she didn't even know
me i paint
and my biggest problem is that i want to
be cool but i'm not cool because i try
to be cool don't do that just stay
yourself like as i was at a party
recently and i saw a girl that i happen
to know as i walked in she said hey
brent easily could have just said hi but
instead i looked at her i pointed and i
went hey jane the dame i was like damn
it get the car mike get the car
what happened i rhymed you rhymed
already just get the car mike
all my friends are outside like what
happened my buddy's like dr seuss over
here ruined the party again
but exit to the worst me i can't leave a
conversation cause i always want to say
something smart or charming when i'm
walking away but like i've learned that
like i'm not smart enough to walk and
talk like you ever tried to say
something smart or charming when you're
walking away but then like your brain
the mouth doesn't work and actual words
don't even come out you ever do that and
try to be a person because as i'm
leaving that same girl was like it was
good to see you i'm like yeah hey you
got a four-line tape
[Laughter]
mike the car
i tried to justify to my head like maybe
she just stinks out of stroke and i
handled her well
you ever do that then realize you're
walking the wrong way you got to go back
you're like damn it
but then i was like it's okay i'll get
another chance but then she threw me
like have a good night i was like yeah
keep the rain down keep the rain down
what do you prince mike the car i'm not
doing well
why are you walking in circles why are
you asking questions instead of getting
a car you're the worst designated driver
ever she's looking at you weird she's
still there yeah what should i do say
something
mike
help dude that was weirder i know it was
weird just please get the car please i'm
not doing well and i'm getting dizzy i
need the help are you okay cat in the
hat cat in the hat
did you just say cat nah yes i did just
please help do you need me to push you
in the right direction push a penis push
a penis if you say push a penis mike
just get the car i'm brent morton thank
you
[Applause]